*Music*
[British soundtracks] In a few moments, he will have written the most laughable jokes in the world ...
As a consequence he will die laughing
*Laughter*
* Loud laughter *
First, I think it is wrong to say that any of them is better than the other.
I find it somewhat disturbing when some people say British comedy is always smarter, or more subtle.
Have you seen episodes of 'Arrested Development', '21 jump street 'or even' spongebob '.
"Be careful, Patrick (simple), to be a heavy responsibility artist"
"Every work of art is as a child, and must be treated as well."
"Come on, I'd just draw a cartoon!"
"Well, why did not you say that ?!"
[Narrator] There are inevitably intelligent texts on both ends of the Atlantic (meaning America and Europe).
But this does not answer the question.
What makes them different?
After weeks of searching, my answer is still "I do not know", but to try.
[British voice commentary] "No one will read it and stay alive."
* Spirits *
* I started laughing *
* Loud laughter *
*you die*
[Ricky Gervais] No, I do not change it, I mean ..
.. I mean the difference, if we talked about the great Britain and America -
Sorry, the rest of the world.
[Narrator] I think it is better to take a British comedy and see how it changed depending on the American adaptation.
"What's the difference between David Brent and Michael Scott?"
By the second season the American show "the office" began its journey away from the UK origin.
So we see a subtle cinematic change in the brightness of the lights in the office,
While the original offer is only to distinguish it from the British version ...
... The brightness of the added lights seems to serve a metaphor for adaptation in general.
[Ricky Gervais] But the big difference is that the Americans are more optimistic.
This is due to the fact that the Americans are told that they can be future presidents of America, and they can.
The British were told, "This will not happen to you." They carry it, they carry it with them.
There is no doubt that America has fueled the show Michael Scott had his mistakes but there is hope.
In one episode he was not invited to Jim's party, but he appeared anyway, really hurt and bitter.
"Wow, open the morgue for this thing!"
[Narrator] He chose a song for the duo and no one would sing with him.
Jim forcibly joins them, smiling at Michael with a big artificial smile and generally a happy ending to the ring.
But when lead David Brent is still funny, but funny differently.
No one will pity him. They just watch awkward.
* Dance and snore sounds *
[Ruway] There is no happy ending and not optimistic.
Or see how both characters end up in the show.
- Warning (burning) -
Michael Scott resigns to move with fiancée to Colorado
David Brent begs to regain his job.
PRINT will strive doubly.
I really will. I know I was complicit.
.. and I will overturn this place
If we say only that it is not final now.
[Narrator] Of course this does not include your Christmas, which was happier.
Frey put it this way: American comic here like John Bellushi or someone like him
You know this scene in the "Animal House" where a musician-
Fellow plays folk music on guitar.
John Bellushi picks up the guitar and destroys it.
She loved the cinema. He just smashes it and then shakes ...
The eyebrows rise and the camera rises: "Oh my God, it's so wonderful."
Well, the British comedian wants to play the role of popular singer.
* Laugh *
We want to play failure.
*singing*
[Narrator] So perhaps the difference is the American dream optimistic against the dark British reality.
At least that's what many people think.
Frey Europe is basically just a group of genes from people who said their ancestors:
I do not think I can take risks - hak, I can not risk.
America is a gene pool - people say: Let's risk!
Let's try!
[Narrator] But I think the answer is very easy, because you have to ignore the fact that
Americans love failure, like Shawn from Shawn dead
- Many modern American sit-ins are characterized by losers who never get salvation.
* BGM *
Frankly, I think it is an old theory.
Last TV era "Married and has children", "Seinfeld" and "Friends"
Always showing a wise classic guy who has always been a funny line one for each position.
Seinfeld Permit You know how to book-
You do not know how to book (hold it)?
* Laugh *
[Narrator] But I think in the past ten years
We began to see self-realization of this optimism "American Dream" - the style of comedy.
In "Always Bright [in Philadelphia]" there is certainly this feeling of that feeling of hope in the characters.
They think they can do anything.
But they always take it very far by turning to violence, cruelty and joy.
Criticism is almost on "American optimism." In America you assume to succeed, but at what cost?
[Male actor] See, if we use a weapon, we will certainly need a muffler.
[The other actor] Abdul?
[Male actor] fine, no weapons, no weapons. Error ... Piano Wires, OK, maybe we can use piano wires.
Look, whatever, I must be the man who pulls the trigger on this thing.
[Narrator] not to mention their failure always and face the consequences.
There seems to be no one thing that ever works for Larry in "curb your enthusiasm".
Larry I Need Them !! [Officer] Get out of the car, please. (Larry), come on! are you serious?!
[Narrator] The episode ends with "Loi" with his beloved god running to a helicopter to escape from him. Can not be more compassionate than that.
So maybe some American comedy is laughing at the hope and nature of the past sit-ins.
Or American comedy may turn into that British irony.
Or maybe we will always keep this American optimism in our hearts.
Even in the millennium, where the American dream seems to do nothing but spoil us,
But will always be rooted in our culture and our beliefs to "ignore" them and keep trying.
[Male actor] I will not take "no" to answer because I just refuse to do so because I am a winner,
Winners - do not listen to words like "no", "do not do" or "stop!"
These words are not just in our dictionaries.
[Narrator] I know this topic so many people are passionate about it, but I hope in the comments
Do not get too hot. At least, I do not expect a sort of Spanish Inquisition.
[In the scene] * play dramatic music *
[Main actor] Nobody expects the Spanish Inquisition!
[Narrator] Thanks for watching!
*Music*
www.patreon.com/nowyouseeit